we start with Kevin Frazier at Madame
tusso's New York in Times Square with an
update on beloved comedian Sinbad Kev
yeah Michelle you know Sinbad had a
stroke two years ago and is learning to
walk again now his family and close
friends are revealing the extent of the
damage and his long road to recovery
I never thought that war was me you can
turn life around like this what is his
condition right now he's in the process
of rehabbing learning to to walk and
talk learning to enunciate words and and
get his Mobility back I spoke
exclusively today with Sinbad's longtime
friend Phyllis Johnson after his family
released these heartbreaking photos of
his secret struggle the 66 year old was
given a 30 chance of survival
when we see him in the hospital on a
ventilator we see him working with the
Walker and physical rehab center was
there concern that he might not make it
yeah I think I think that's a concern
that everybody have now he's just he's
on the road to recovery why did he
decide to tell fans about the condition
now I think you know Sinbad is very
private he just wanted to wait until he
was ready to be at a place in time where
he felt comfortable explaining
Sinbad's family set up a website asking
for donations quote the cost of therapy
far exceed what insurance covers he had
a smooth looking brother at the helm
the star showed signs of the stroke in
his last TV appearance on the Donald
glover-led comedy Atlanta the episode
aired just four weeks ago doing comedy
was always crucial to him it's just like
medicine it keeps me going every day and
I can look at the the stupid side of
anything and I think it keeps everything
perspective to me that nothing is really
that serious the Beloved comedian has
weathered financial difficulties before
filing for bankruptcy in 2009 and in
2013. I lost something my life saving
was like four million dollars it was all
good money is made every day
it's your job to go out and get it
he is now leading that fight along with
the donation website they're also
allowing fans to purchase Sinbad's first
ever collectible action figure proceeds
go towards his recovery there's always a
risk of another stroke Dr Shelby Halsey
a stroke recovery expert not involved in
Sinbad's case tells us comprehensive
Aftercare is vital it's going to
it's kind of cool but the emotional but
somebody who is extremely motivated that
definitely helps
he's a fighter and he has all the right
people around him his wife Meredith his
children he's taken all the right steps
as far as physical therapy diet and
everything to keep make sure that he's
ready to go when he steps back out there
he's not giving up
[Music]